hey guys what's up this is andrew for
chainsenses.com so in this video guys i
want to make a big update on amc gme go
through everything that happened this
week it was a pretty tough week guys i
know so let's try to understand what is
happening and what can happen next let's
get into it
[Music]
alright guys so let's start with i'm
gonna do some technical analysis on amc
on gme we're gonna go through the
synthetic show the option market we're
also gonna try to see what kind of flows
are involved in the stock because this
is i think key to understand how we can
get out from this bad situation we're in
for the past few months and understand
actually what can drive the flows back
into amc so first let's do some uh
technical analysis guys i'm usually i'm
going to start on a daily time frame
i'm having here amc child daily time
frame so you guys know this technical
analysis so we are since we broke out
from the strangle guys that was here
below 38 we are in a severe down trend
the question is when is it gonna stop so
to do that to us to try to answer that
question we need to look for reversal
signals all right so what is a reversal
signal it can be a breakout it can be
some candlestick pattern it can be some
momentum information some momentum
signal so here what do we have guys
first let's try to
check for the natural supports because
uh supports levels are where we have
liquidity where we have buyers waiting
to get in so
here guys i'm talking about the 14.5
level for quite some time this was a
level i
i thought we could go to and found some
support because we had those reactions
look guys remember that it's very you
know it's basic things but it's working
pretty well guys on any type of stock
whenever you are far from a support
level that has not been touched for
quite some time the first time you go
there you almost always have a strong
positive reaction so here one two three
four five six reactions so pretty
obvious and this was a liquidity area we
went right through it guys uh with a
strong candle so you know this is a
support so when we came here we had a
strong rebound i was personally a buyer
here i was a buyer also a little bit
higher so i mean for now well the trades
have done in the move down are located
between 15 and 17 so they are not
winning trades yet but i'm very
confident we get bad guys to this area
this is the resistance camera where we
should be back sooner or later and then
let's see i think unfortunately this
process to be really back guys on high
levels like below the 30 area will take
time all right so let me first finish
here uh what i think might happen from
here so as you guys can see we had those
hammer candles all right we had one last
week i did a video about that hammer
candles are reversal patterns the reason
why the reversal patterns guys is
because are trapping a lot of bears so
why are they trapping best because we
open the day here we move lower so here
you know bears are selling and i'm
afraid it's not only best i'm afraid
it's buyers that just get stopped so
that's not giving the same effect as if
it was new short positions that are open
all right if you open the short position
and you get a hang you don't want to do
it again all right but if you are buyer
and you stop lost your position here you
might be buying here as well so i'm
afraid some buyers got you know stopped
here and got back in here and just did a
double losing trade so if it's that of
course it's not helping for booze to
take back control so we don't really
know who was involved in this selling
area in this bear trap but we had a bear
trap here that then was followed by a
shooting star guys which is a bull trap
so we had bear trap bull trap then
strong move down another bear trap guys
below the 14.5 level we opened the day
on friday uh roughly around the support
level 14.5 we went lower again i'm
afraid it was stop losses i don't know
if it's short adding and then killing
the position it's impossible to know but
it's still a reversal candle guys so
what can i say guys we had a lot of
traps it's not easy to actually
trade breakouts on amc so what i'm
personally doing is just trying to you
know buy the deep which is a dangerous
game guys but right now we are still
holding about 14.5 but once a support is
tested you know i told you the first
time you always have a positive reaction
but the second and third time it's not
guaranteed at all guys even the first
time is not guaranteed of course but
it's very likely it happens but now it's
been three times retesting it so i'm
afraid if we get back again to it it
will break okay let's be prepared for
that guys you know i'm here to tell you
everything that i think might happen so
this is one of the scenario you need to
be prepared to if it happens what we
will probably see is a quick move to the
12 area and just like we had here then
the rebound and then you know probably
we're gonna end up finally this uh
bearish cycle that we've been in for the
past two months i know guys it's been
very tough
for everyone
what's happening to us is very brutal
guys it's a very violent uh mental
process because we have hope uh and then
the hope just vanishes whenever you know
we have those bull traps so it's like
you know of so many so many traps guys
it's you know not easy i know that but
uh hopefully it's gonna end soon so once
again 12 is the next support level if we
come back to 14.5 it might break yes so
be prepared for that uh the bullish case
is that we just bounce uh right away on
monday uh just you know
hover here a little bit find uh come
back to this resistance that has been
tested for now one two three times only
so probably get rejected get back some
energy and break it hopefully yes so
this is what we're looking for so those
types of breakouts that could happen
around i don't know mid feb you know
something like this if we're really
bullish even slightly before so this is
uh what i think might happen i think
this correction is going to be ended
soon but it's going to be very much
related to what is happening on the
global market tomorrow guys i'm going to
post a video on spy and triple q go
watch it because
right now the sentiment of the market is
just bad guys it's bearish you know i've
been talking about it for quite some
time but you know this uh increase this
rate hike is not looking good because of
the inflation so basically this is what
i wanted to show you guys what is
happening is that we have massive
massive outflows from amc who is selling
okay some paper hands uh apes might be
selling but the big sellers guys are
the big money players that were involved
in the street that both here all the way
up guys all the institutional clients
let me show you that
i have an article guys here that is
showing like basically uh seven civilly
undervalued stocks all right so this is
an article showing that a lot of
institutional clients were adding to amc
all the way up guys uh probably you know
around the 20 30 levels uh last year and
they keep adding to it all right russell
investment group bought a new position
in amc this was written on jan 28 all
right both 30 000 shares
uh blah blah blah and what is
interesting so they tell us that a lot
of
clients were buying and selling amc last
year but mostly buying this is i don't
know if you see it well guys
on this chart you can see institutional
buying and selling by quarter for amc so
first quarter second quarter third
quarter they were buying all the way up
so they were helping the price to go
higher and the fourth quarter guys so
basically when we were here the first
quarter is starting here guys they
stopped buying all right so here they
were not buying anymore and look what
happened we just moved
brutally down so what i'm saying is that
we need those guys to be back apes by
themselves created this movement right
that they were at the inception of the
first squeeze but the institutional
clients are the guys that are making the
market move i'm talking about every type
of market they were involved in the
bitcoin rally as well when we broke out
above 20 000 uh one or two years ago and
they were the ones involved here as well
guys and we need them to be back and
those guys
i know bit how they invest you know and
they won't you know go in very
speculative stocks
unless the bullish sentiment is really
back on the global market right if
there's there is fear in the market they
will keep reducing the position so i'm
not sure what is the position right now
i don't know maybe they're gonna now
stop selling because we arrive at levels
that are supposed to be you know even
analysts say that the company presently
has an average rating
average price target of 12 okay so
we don't care what enemies say i know
but those guys they care and if now they
see that the
consensus is 12 for amc which is of
course wrong they will probably stop
selling if we arrive to 12. so what i'm
saying is that if those guys were the
ones creating the selling power they
will stop that soon and if the bullish
sentiment comes back on the global
market they will start buying again
which will help a lot amc to go higher
so we need them to be back and once
again tomorrow i'm posting your video on
spun triple q that is showing you guys
what can happen on the global market and
this is key to understand what will
happen on amc okay here guys
let's check quickly what is the
synthetic short
what is happening i want to check
the max pane
right so max payne for option expiring
on the on february 18th so in two weeks
is 22 23 so doesn't mean we're gonna
close there but it's just a price that
would make sense we close to on february
18th okay because this is the maximum
pain for option holders the maximum loss
they would have if all the options
expire on this level so market makers
would likely try to push the price
towards that direction so 22 23 we don't
have any synthetic short at the moment
because we have a lot of fruit options
in this market as well that is
cancelling the effect of the coal
options we still have eighteen percent
of uh regular short interest so twenty
percent of total shocks dtc at two
percent so right now the synthetic shock
gas is back to zero but as you know it's
gonna grow on the upside if you go to
three you can see guys
okay it goes
to five percent so it's not impressive
all right so we don't have as many cool
options as we used to have so we can see
there is you know people you know are
not for now increasing their positions
on amc and like i said guys that's why i
think this process will need time so if
you want me to try to give you roughly
in the bullish case guys what could
happen we could go back to 30 maybe in
april then get rejected and you know it
would be maybe around june 22 yes this
is my scenario so yeah just you know
give it some time maybe don't
look at you know that many
analysis you know just try to rest guys
i know it's difficult guys to see this
happening i'm everyday guys here with
you uh watching the stock as well and
you know i'm used to that i'm a
professional trader i mean i used to be
a professional shutter so i i am used to
get this pressure you know when looking
at childs but guys just take some time
take some rest guys in it's it's not
going to come right away we need a
little bit of time but it will be back
i'm very sure of that so what else can
we say okay so you see i told you guys
yeah uh and i'm very curious to know
guys here i told you it was margin calls
right uh last week this is what i was
saying because it was looking like like
shorts were taking profits here around
the 14.5 level so once again we never
know who is buying is it apes is it
institutional clients is it headstrong's
headphones covering the shorts it can be
any of those three types of investors
but if it's shorts covering guys we will
get so this was on the 24th of january
so you guys know that in two weeks we
will get the new regular short for this
is as of 14th of january i'm showing you
guys this 19 was on 14th of jan so the
24th of january a move is not included
there so if we see this is dropping it
means that shots are covering so i don't
know if it's good to cover uh low or not
but i mean every buyer is welcome into
the amc thread if shots want to cover
they they should do it and it will help
push the price action higher guys and
then they will probably reload their
short position here and then they would
be able to be squeezed all right guys
let me now do gme i know that i use most
of them spend more time on amc so i'm
gonna try to spend as much time on gme
guys so what do we have we have a bit
the same situation we broke out from
this triangle guys you know around 170
and since then we are just brutally
brutally going down so is the move down
finished or not so the 14.5 of amc is
the equivalent level of 87 on gme why 87
guys i'm talking about this level for a
couple of weeks month because just
simple thing guys when you want to find
some support check the previous lows
where you had those reactions you know
and here it was just the low that we had
on the 26th of feb so it means there
were a lot of buyers here and the same
buyers are
six months later even
one year later guys the same buyers are
waiting at the same level this is the
beauty of technical analysis is that you
know the market has memory and we had
this positive reaction and same thing as
we have this very strong reversal
candles that we have here that are
trapping a lot of beds okay we have this
one bullish candle
then here's shooting star guys bull trap
and then here again
sort of hammer candle the only thing i
can say guys is that we have a lot of
those reversal candles a lot of fake
outs in this market right now i would
say again guys that this is a buoy
situation that we we have reached the 87
level that we somehow needed to reach so
that you know shorts take profits or
boos are reloading once again the 87
level is the low with the previous flow
we had here and it's also if you measure
you apply feed projection uh you you
measure the a wave you apply to the top
of the b wave and you have the 61.8
percent projection feed projection at
87. it's a double reason to think 87 is
a support level and we have those
reversal candles so it's looking great
right so now i didn't show you guys
anything related to momentum and volume
let's do some analysis about that i'm
building a course guys then it's going
to be released soon it's going to be
amazing so for all of you guys who are
in the discord community you're of
course gonna have a massive massive
discount and you're gonna have uh you're
gonna be fully refunded if you don't
like the course and this course guys is
gonna help you to understand the market
dynamics so that you know you're able to
analyze the flows just like i'm doing
for quite some time so once again amc
and gme examples are very very tough to
actually analyze but there is a lot a
lot of information that you can get from
the flows even if there are many traps
so here for example let's try to see
what the volume and momentum is telling
us so look i'm on a daily timeframe so
momentum going lower guys and the price
actually going lower so we don't have
any information about divergences okay
we are looking for this type of
information when we are talking about
momentum we can also check the other way
around we can check if the bearish trend
is sustainable or not so we can check if
you have some bearish hidden divergence
so we connect the highs and we check if
the momentum is making higher highs and
it's not so we don't have any bearish
hidden divergence as well so we don't
have any bearish signal we don't have
any bullish signals so we don't have any
information coming from the momentum
because we don't have any divergence so
what else can we do now we can do some
volume analysis and you guys uh know if
you are checking my videos for some time
that before a reversal we need a period
of balance between bulls and bears okay
it's always starting the same way bears
and control massive moves high
volatility high volume just like here
you know those big candles that are
showing that you know bears are full of
confidence and that they want to push
the price lower so for example here this
was very bearish guys and i think i told
you that because uh you can see the
moves are high the volume training is
high so right now what do we have we
still have those very high moves okay
and the volume involved at least it's
green bars but i want to see that guys
this is what we're looking for for a
reversal right we're looking for very
low volume
that is showing that bears are ready to
let it go for now we don't have it so
what can we expect we can still have a
strong move up okay but then we would
need so that's why i put that here we
would need to consolidate yes so
probably around 115 level this would be
a level that makes sense to me so my
preferred scenario is that we go
we go up to the 115 level once again
only if the global market is you know
taking a breath as well in the move down
otherwise i'm afraid we will not be able
to see some positive moves on gme or amc
we need the global market to be back as
well and if it does jimmy would probably
come back to the 150 level then we need
to consolidate yes once again we need to
have those low volume low volatility
just like we had here this was a good
area for breakout but unfortunately
happened on the downside so it got
followed by move down right right now we
need the same thing to happen on the
upside and the levels to watch would be
here guys around so 115 okay 115 maybe
in two weeks this would be a good level
to be and to break out above uh and
hopefully then we will have the bullish
sentiment coming back institutional
clients buying as well because it's the
same players involved in this trade let
me now show you guys quickly what we
have here on the
option market
okay
so a bit the same situation
now we have some synthetic short on jme
we have three percent of synthetic short
at this level we have 15 of regular
short interest and same thing guys i
want to check this number in one or two
weeks when the next uh regular short
interest
value is going to be released to see if
shots have covered or not the tdc is 3.3
so it means that shorts are still under
pressure but of course it's not gonna
squeeze from here we need to bring the
price uh higher for those squeeze
effects to uh occur and the maximum pain
guys is 130 guys right on february 18th
okay
so it's pretty let me see if i have all
the strikes here
[Music]
yeah all of them is good
okay so the the maximum pain is around
120 guys 130
something like this you can see it's
pretty much flat so the area
11520 would make sense for february 18th
guys and the last thing i wanted to tell
you guys because once again i'm here to
do technical analysis and i need to show
you the alternative scenario so if we
break
below 87 once again it's been testing
twice if we go there a third time it
would not be looking good guys so uh if
it breaks because we need to be prepared
for that if the global market thanks
more which is possible next support guys
is at 40 so it's very far i know but
unfortunately i don't have any support
between 87 and 40. so doesn't mean we
absolutely need to go there it just
means that it's gonna be very uh you
know hard to tread very volatile so
let's hope we don't have this breakout
below 87 for now it's looking good guys
so once again i'm trying always to stay
positive in my videos guys because this
is what we need some positivity we are
here guys in the stream for more than
one year so we need to support each
other i'm always gonna be here guys to
make some technical analysis even right
now it's not looking great guys but i'm
here to tell you what i think might
happen the situation so once again to
conclude the same thing as as i've been
saying for quite some time guys we need
time the squeeze won't happen i think in
the coming one two three months uh we
might see some bullish price action
coming back yes this is very likely to
happen but not a big squeeze happening
right now yes because once again we need
every player to be involved in the trade
and those guys the big money players
they won't get back in unless we have
some very bullish sentiment on the
global market which i think would happen
again in a couple of months so that's it
for me i hope you guys enjoyed this
video and if you did please don't forget
to click on the sub like and bell button
so you're gonna be the first to know
when i upload anything new and stay
close to shore see you guys